- Sunshine Laundromat is a small
laundromat in Brooklyn
that as you pass through it you realize
has a little more than meets the eye.
Because in the very back
is a secret door which
opens onto a bar filled
with some of the greatest
pinball ever assembled into one location.
We're Atlas Obscura and these are
infrequently asked
questions with Peter Rose
the owner of Sunshine Laundromat.
- What is the weirdest
thing you've found in a
laundry machine?
I've only found day to day
objects in laundry machines
but actually in one of the drop off orders
one of our attendants once found (bleep).
Used (bleep).
I'm Peter, owner of Sunshine Laundromat
in Greenpoint, Brooklyn, and today we'll be
answering some questions
for Atlas Obscura.
Are drunk people better
at pinball or laundry?
I would say likely pinball.
Drunk people doing laundry,
I think they're just
making their clothes wet, taking them out
and shoving them in a bag.
Pinball's probably the
best place for drunks.
If you could have a third hidden business
behind the bar, what would it be?
My ideal would be if
we could have something
that involved more dogs.
A business with large dogs.
A kennel, a litter of puppies back there.
Does your liquor license
cover the laundromat?
Our license does cover the laundromat.
It's somewhat by choice
and largely by confusion.
The community board, our attorneys
and even the state
liquor authority I think
were just so confused by this whole thing
that they just said, yes.
Where can patrons stand if
they want to simultaneously
enjoy the aroma of the laundromat and bar?
Ooh, in the bathroom?
The middle ground?
How do you curate the items
in your vending machine?
Many of the items in the vending machine
are just random articles
that I'll see in a store
that would physically
fit in a vending machine.
But one would not expect to find in there.
Selling a dollar for two
dollars I think was just,
really just an attempt at humor.
And it's highly profitable.
It's our best margin item here.
But much to my surprise,
people started buying it
on a near daily basis.
And we had one person that came in here,
bought it and he thought
there was a hidden gift
behind it, presumably something worth
thousands of dollars.
So he was a little
disappointed when he found out
he got a dollar for two dollars.
Has there ever been a combo
laundry and pinball machine?
Who wrote this question?
You're a genius.
This is amazing, we're gonna talk.
Who wouldn't wanna play a
laundry pinball machine?
Quick, add the bleach, softener.
Netflix just approached you about making
a pinball and/or laundry themed series.
What's the title of the
show and what is it about?
Title of the show, Sunshine Laundromat.
It would probably have to be about dogs.
Oh, we have subliminal dogs everywhere.
Hidden dogs, it's a treasure hunt.
Just nothing in the bar area.
Department of Health doesn't like that.
If you could be buried
inside a pinball machine
which one would you choose?
Oh, wow, all-time favorite
could be Medieval Madness.
So I might have to spend the
rest of my life inside there.
As great as many of the other games are,
that's one that I could
come back to endlessly.
Does this place have a lost and found?
If so, what's the
weirdest thing that's ever
been in there?
We do have a lost and found.
It's in one of our broken old dryers
that somebody set ablaze.
The weirdest thing that's
ever been in there,
I think for a while it may
have been a nativity scene.
Although I'm not sure that was lost.
That might have been a
little more deliberate.
What's the most money
you've ever physically held
in quarters?
I would say the most I've
ever lugged over to the bank
in one trip is probably about $5,000.
At which point I needed
to visit a chiropractor.
What questions haven't
we asked that we should?
That might be how did we
know we were successful
beyond looking at finances?
I think one of my favorite
instances was when
we received a certified
letter from the state
liquor authority offering
their condolences
about the place not existing.
Meanwhile they just couldn't find us.
Which was so flattering that the whole
speakeasy concept actually worked.
In what ways is pinball
a metaphor for life?
Gotta come back to that.